Uh,
are you shocked at the amount of people
that live in western societies here in
Norway,
especially when we were in Sweden a
couple of days ago,
but all the countries that we've been in
that live in free societies yet are
completely afraid to say what they
think.
Is it absolutely shocking to you?
I think the most.
I think what I've been most shocked
about in all of that is what's happened
in the UK with the police starting to
prosecute people for crimes of
offensiveness.
That's just.
And I think that's probably partly
because I'm an,
I mean I see that as broadly reflective
of,
of something that's happening in the
West in general,
but it's particularly shocking and
appalling to me as a,
as a western Canadian,
you know,
because obviously Canada was part of the
British empire and when I grew up,
like there was a pretty tight affinity
still in western Canada with the British
empire.
I mean our,
our maps where the dominion of Canada,
it was still pink,
you know,
it was still a part of the British
empire.
We saying God save the Queen Constantly
at public gatherings.
That's gone by the wayside and so,
and you know,
I've always regarded British common law
and the British parliamentary tradition
as well.
One of it perhaps the highest
achievement of western civilization.
I mean you could argue about that,
but it's,
it's in the top 10,
let's say,
and then to see the Brits who also have
this phenomenal sense of humor,
this ability to say anything,
no matter how outrageous about anyone
and to include themselves in the joke,
right?
Which is such an elegant way of
expressing comedic freedom to see them
going down this road is just,
it just,
it's,
it's what is it exactly?
Well,
it's deeply saddening.
That's for sure.
And,
and what's horrifying and it's not
exactly the right wording.
I don't know what the word for it is
there.
Certainly sorrow that's associated with
a disbelief.
It's also that at,
at,
at watching that happen in what I still
think is the central core of the idea of
individual sovereignty and freedom as
expressed across the western world.
And so,
and then there's similar manifestations
of that everywhere else,
but the police per prosecuting people
for,
you know,
asking people to turn in their neighbors
if they say something offensive.
And that's happening in the UK.
Yeah.
Litter.
Well,
we saw that,
that,
you know,
somebody sent me posters,
pictures of posters in the Scottish
subway,
in the,
in the metro,
in the tube,
you know,
saying inviting people to inform on
their neighbors for being offensive.
It's like,
what the hell,
what,
what?
So I knew this was coming because.
Because I knew
we brought our first speech laws in
Canada back in the 19 eighties.
We were after this character named Ernst
Zandel,
who is particularly despicable piece of
work,
hard hat wearing,
right wing antisemitism Holocaust
denier.
You know,
he had it all that guy
and it was his
shenanigans,
careless malevolent shenanigans that
entice Canadians into producing hate
speech legislation.
I thought,
no,
that's,
that's not good.
It's not good.
You're making a big mistake.
We're going to pay for this.
It's going to unfold over a long time.
Who defines hate
the crucial issue.
It's not like it's a scientific category
to judgment and the answer is those whom
you least want to have the power to
define it because they're the ones that
will take that power to themselves.
And if you think that isn't gonna Affect
what you get to say,
well you've got another thing coming.
So I think it's,
I think it's,
we're going to pay for it and hopefully
hopefully we'll wake up and push back
before we have to pay too high a price
to pay for it.
So.
Yeah.
And we're going to deserve to pay for it
too.
He's talking to you
last night.
Last night that
was on this British show called question
time,
which is very famous British show.
And there was a,
um,
a woman parliamentarian.
They're from Ireland who,
who is pretty bright.
I like listening to her,
but I'm the host asked me about this
character named count.
Dang,
Kyla,
I don't know if you know about him and
his girlfriend.
He's a comedian while he thinks he's a
comedian and.
Well,
but you know,
there are lots of Comedians who think
they're comedians that aren't funny.
And I'm not saying he's not funny
because other people think that he's a
comedian too,
but he presents himself as a comedian.
Count.
Dang killer.
I mean that's actually a joke,
that name and his girlfriend had a pug
and I liked count Dan Kennedy because he
hated that Pug and I'm not very fond of
pugs.
I think they're hideous little creatures
and,
and you know,
I don't really hate them if a pug comes
along then all pet it and everything,
but it's just sort of like the,
the,
this little dog with these bugs,
you know,
if you hit it on the back of the head,
the eyes will pop out.
And so because they've been so
genetically mishandled and so,
I don't know,
man,
it's just,
you realize we're putting this on
youtube and you're just done.
You're unleashing a whole new world.
People.
I know,
I know.
Whatever,
whatever.
So you can have your and you can love
it.
My Dad had this dog that was so damn
hideous and useless that it was just a
miracle and he loved it to death.
And so,
and you know,
that's fine,
but there's kind of an ironic attitude
in the dismissal of pugs and Denckla
didn't like his girlfriend's punk.
And so he thought he'd play a mean trick
and,
or amine slash funny trick and teach it
to do a hail Hitler salute.
Which I actually thought was quite
funny.
It's like I don't,
look,
I don't see that as glorifying Hitler
hits up Pug for God's sake.
It wasn't,
uh,
it wasn't a,
what do you call those Doberman,
you know,
it was a pug that's like teaching a wrap
to do hail Hitler.
Salute.
I love how this has come down to the
breed of dogs with you.
These things matter in terms of their,
the way they're represented,
you know,
and then,
he,
he taught it to so horrible.
He and I'm gonna be so killed for this.
He taught him to do it's little salute
when he said gas the Jews,
which is not funny.
It except it's horribly funny,
you know,
that's the thing.
Well look,
and so yeah,
you laugh.
That's right.
Because you're all horrible and you
know,
and you know perfectly well that it's
horribly funny
and you know,
we need,
we need to be able to be horribly funny
because life is horrible and we and we
need to be able to find.
We need to be able to allow people the
freedom to find the ability to transcend
that horror with comedy and a mark of a
free society is that comedians can be
just exactly what the is,
which there people who push the edge of
what's acceptable.
If you're a brilliant comedian,
you get right to the edge,
right?
And you dance there and the audience is
thinking,
Sarah Silvermans a good example of that.
You know,
because you can just see her.
She's gone all politically correct
recently.
But when she was in her heyday,
you could just see Sarah,
she's so smart.
You'd see you're sitting there and she'd
think of something just spectacularly
evil and horrible.
And she think,
oh,
and then she say it,
you know,
and everyone would just crack up because
like the darkest part of their soul had
once thought something like that and she
dared to outer red 10.
And by honoring it she also
simultaneously transcended it,
you know?
And that's the beauty of comedy and,
and,
and well.
So anyways,
they went after Dane,
Kyla and nailed him legally.
And I thought that's an,
that's in Great Britain as well last
night.
So they brought this up on,
on question time and you know,
the Irish woman who said she went off on
a talk about how terrible Kristallnacht
wasn't,
what an awful thing Auschwitz Holocaust
was.
It's like,
well,
you're not that morally virtuous to
notice that.
You know what I mean?
It's like it didn't have anything to do
with the topic at hand.
It's like,
yet you wouldn't say that.
You notice that unless you were implying
that where there are people around you,
including this count,
dank killer,
who didn't notice that.
Okay.
It had nothing to do with whether he
should have been prosecuted for his
stupid joke.
And you can say,
well,
you could say I was a stupid joke,
which it certainly was.
You could say that it was a hateful
joke,
which I don't agree with by the way,
but you could say that and I think you
could,
you could make a credible case for that.
But then to say that because you think
that the holocaust was bad,
he should be criminally prosecuted.
It's like,
no,
sorry man,
you've crossed the line and there's no
excuse for it.
And so that's part of what's worrisome
about the state of discourse in the free
West.
That same thing,
comedians won't go to university
campuses,
same thing.
You don't get to be funny.
So if you can't be funny then you're not
free.
You know,
the gesture and the king's courts,
the only person who gets to tell the
truth.
And if the king is such a tyrant that he
kills his gesture,
then you know that the evil king is in
charge.
And so when we can't tolerate our
comedians,
it's like,
well,
there you go.
They're the canaries in the coal mine as
far as I'm concerned.
Thank you.
My wife that I wouldn't hit any hornets
with any Hornet's nest with sticks for
like a day and now I just hit a big
hornet's nest with the stick.
So sorry Tammy.
She's here somewhere.
Yeah.
Give it up for Jordan's wife,
by the way.
She's been.
Thank you.